- So what memories of
Chadwick do you have?
Do you have any great ones?
- Let's say, what was
maybe about 15 years ago?
I was given, thankful and grateful for a
honorary PhD from Howard university.
- [Kelly] Oh, wow.
- [Taylor] Yeah. So I went there.
- That's amazing.
- Thanks.
And he was my guide, he
was my student guide.
- [Kelly] Wait, like before he was acting?
- [Taylor] Before anything and everything.
- [Kelly] Are you serious?
- [Taylor] Yeah, he was an actor there.
- What a full circle moment.
- Mhmm.
- Did he tell you that,
whenever y'all were?
- He told me that at the opening party,
at the premier party.
I was like, ahhhh, you cold water.
(laughter)
I can't hold water. You know.
- He didn't tell you the
whole time you were filming?
- And we sat next to
each other every morning
in the makeup chair.
You know as we're getting
our lines, and our accents,
and our work together for the day.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- He's just amazing. And
he reminded me of that.
- I would've had to have
been like, blah, we've met.
- Yeah, me too. Me too.
- Oh my gosh.
That's so cool though, I love
those full circle moments.
That's really, really cool.
- Amazing, amazing man.